hydration that's pretty risky stuff
surefour needs to control pint
otherwise uh yeah the power is gonna
have a bad time we'll see what hydration
does try
unbelievable what is this
nyxl and here comes pine gets one gets
two
looking for a bit more gets another one
are you kidding me this guy is gonna
single-handedly
change the point back over it's gonna
kill everybody oh
okay big boss pine is on the scene
not many widowmakers would go for this
play
wood and he just absolutely nails it
here even the machine
what a flick
[Music]
he's missing home he's missing family
he's missing friends he's missing korean
food
and he just doesn't seem to have the
energy to play
the only problem is you're sat around
waiting for minutes at a time for fights
that don't end
while everybody grinds up ultimates to
then get that wombo combo
but it's not as exciting as watching
pine you know kill five people
hey folks before we get into the video i
want to make sure that you know that
this one is brought to you by geico
excelling at overwatch isn't easy but
you know what is
switching to geico 15 minutes could save
you 15 or more on car insurance so check
out the link in the description for more
info
all right back to the video in season
one of the overwatch league
damage heroes were the backbone of the
game the plays were exciting the heroes
were flashy and the players who made
them
got to show off their incredible skills
to the world
angle oh my god oh there we go
triple kill from him the huge plays
just tubing up get out valiant
dive the dominant meta at the time gave
us big plays and
even bigger personalities and one of
those personalities was the new york
excelsior's dps
legend big boss pine you can do it
well not that time he can't as he gets
disconnected from his mercy
finds himself in pines crosshairs right
there
and they continue to get he's so aggro
on this mccree he rolls in
somersaults and that's another three
kill life four pines
okay so in the span of uh 25 seconds
they get the deadline
let's see what hydration does
unbelievable
what is this i can't take it anymore
not many widowmakers would go for this
play
but pine wood and he just absolutely
nails it here even to the machine
what a flick beautiful
this guy's a living highlight reel man
pine's rise to stardom was as relentless
as his playstyle
his carefree attitude and his incredible
hitscan abilities
made him a fan favorite in no time but
it wasn't all fun and games
behind the scenes pine was going through
a difficult time dealing with depression
and
panic disorder like pine wasn't really
going to like
take time off but coaches kind of like
felt that kind of something was or
something wrong with pine
and coast so coaches went to pine first
and you know talked to him
and then you know pine opened up and
then he you know told
all the problems and that's how like
pine you know
decided to like take time off overwatch
gave pine a reason to
leave home and pursue his dreams but he
couldn't help but get home sick
he's missing home he's missing family
he's missing friends he's missing korean
food
and he just doesn't seem to have the
energy to play so that's why he's
currently
taking a break but you know what big
boss pine your team got you back and the
fans in here got you back we hope to see
you back on stage
very soon after taking some time for
himself pine returned to nyxl's bench
waiting for his chains to be their
secret weapon but due to a massive
change in the meta
pine never got that chance this combos
worked well for them before but as soon
as they see the defensive setup
they will just simply swap it away
crucial time lost here
for the outlaws
[Applause]
i'm just letting the fans give their uh
the fans here in the studio give their
opinion
well you know you want your team to win
right they're gonna have to play what's
better
i think that after a while we realized
that was maybe not really conducive to
uh
exciting gameplay or at least a varied
you know array of different gameplay
i feel like winning doesn't feel as
satisfying because you're running goats
to win and then
like losing is even worse because you
feel so
useless the rise of the goats meta
brought dps heroes to their knees they
were made almost
obsolete in a game that once relied on
them for its most memorable moments
the shift came so quickly that it left
many players scrambling to learn new
heroes that they weren't used to
uh players when you think back to season
one who had that where it was like pine
he could just play widowmaker widowmaker
mccree like he didn't really kind of
have to play
anything else where i feel like even
players like decay
uh who came in is like a really big
hitscan player uh his first year in the
league he had to play a ton of zarya
because of goats
uh then we've even seen him play genji
like that role is just uh
i think the role of that hit scan like
only player is kind of gone
for pine the goat's meta basically put
him out of a job
he was warming the bench when he should
have been clicking on heads
one of the things blizzard tried to do
to fix the game was introduced two two
to rollock but
that didn't do much to help lagging
viewership or interest in the game
either
and it led former pros like seagull to
express their frustration
the weird part about it is people don't
talk about the game anymore
i i watch a lot of stuff there are
probably less than 10
overwatch youtubers uh the only other
major places for discussions in most
games is one reddit two youtube three
twitch
well turns out most of the twitch
streamers are quitting superstars who
started in overwatch like sinatra were
heading to other games or retiring
and pine joined the ranks of dozens of
players who just didn't see a future in
pro overwatch teams just weren't
signing dps players pine was not finding
himself in the new meta and the pressure
was becoming too much to bear
pine retired and switched to streaming
meanwhile blizzard was desperately
trying to make their game exciting again
whether the meta changes or not
people will end up not liking the
current meta and i already see that
happening like
i've seen people say well goats is dead
and now it's just double sniper and
that's gonna be
terrible or oh now everybody's just
gonna play mccree
and at a certain point i'm like what the
hell do
people want roll walk may have killed
goats but it did not
save overwatch's aim gods see after
goats came double shield which brought
back damage but characters like
widowmaker mccree and ash the hitscan
heroes who rewarded good aim
were not playable and overwatch
continued like that for a while
damage was in meta but hitscan wasn't
and that's what made people realize that
aiming may really be dead in overwatch
by losing their focus on aim blizzard
found that they were making overwatch
boring problem is you're sad around
waiting for minutes at a time
for fights that don't end while
everybody grinds up ultimates to then
get that wombo combo
but it's not as exciting as watching
pine you know kill five people
for lower level players aim never
mattered as much because blizzard never
expect you to master a skill you were
just learning
but for competitive players moving away
from hitscan heroes meant that there was
less incentive for them to get better at
the game's mechanics
shield stuns aoe damage heals
overpowered ultimates
there is a long list of abilities that
were outclassing aim in overwatch
well why would i play a strict damage
dealer like tracer for example
why would i play a strict damage dealer
or mccree or widow or whatever
when i can play a hero that is now kind
of damaged
uh like may so i can still click heads
with the icicle i can freeze people i
have a wall
and i have a massive aoe alt that picks
everybody up in a 10 mile radius like
why am i going to play a damage dealer
when i can do that in an effort to
please everyone
blizzard ended up pissing off a lot of
people instead and folks from across the
community weren't shy about voicing
their concerns
including xqc because shooting shield is
not enjoyable for anybody the pros the
devs the moms
the dads the the pro players
it doesn't matter over the months
blizzard tried
all kinds of things to fix overwatch
some of their attempts worked i want to
remind everybody that the experimental
card
is not targeted at bug fixing or
stability or anything like that
the experimental card is really focused
on
radical gameplay changes or things that
we want to try out
and get your direct player feedback on
then in early july when
season 23 the normal competitive season
starts
competitive open queue will now become
an official mode that will be supported
alongside the role cue
competitive queue right now from as far
as i can tell
the general player base as well as
content creators are the happiest
they've ever been
i've conducted two polls on this
question on youtube and twitter both of
them were overwhelmingly positive and
many notable community members have been
quite vocal on the success of the recent
patches and changes
blizzard has put through to the game and
after tons of patches and
listening to community concerns things
are actually looking a lot better
we've seen a lot faster movement in
terms of balance
which i think has been really good i
think combined with like the the faster
balance in the hero pools it's really
kind of opened things up
this year in terms of overwatch league
and i think uh
you know just building on that well
since the league's over right we've
already seen a ton of balance changes
and
uh big adjustments to the game in
general there are like a but there are a
bunch of competing factors right like
how like the durability of heroes versus
the burst damage potential and such like
that
uh and i believe that after an extensive
amount of iteration and no doubt a lot
of feedback from the pros
right now as we speak uh here at the end
of october the game is in a very good
state balance wise and pine has decided
to give overwatch another chance
i'm feeling better than before so i
don't have a pressure right now and
feeling
feeling good overwatch went through its
fair share of balance challenges over
the years
and dps players were just some of the
casualties along the way
it's encouraging to me at least to see
that not only are we sort of reverse in
the narrative of dps
or aim didn't didn't matter in the
overwatch league but the players
who may maybe even sidelined by that are
also starting to take interest again
it might be too late for overwatch to
win back the hearts of dps players and
fans looking for high octane high skill
matches but pine
is ready for his comeback cause we
haven't seen him playing a bit but we
know how special he is on those heroes
right like the long-range hit scans the
mccrees
where i i think if you put him in that
role to succeed
i think he can be a really powerful
player for your team in certain
situations
uh i think that you know it's a ripe
opportunity for him
especially considering just how far
above the rest he was as a sort of aim
based player
every organization every team needs a
face
i think the fans all unanimously agree
that pine is
that person pine represents new york he
represents nyxl
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages